[Music]
Tylar Aikido I'm a software engineer at
Google and also a member of the Apache
beam project management committee hello
hello everyone my name is Lloyd rice and
I'm confronter and CTO of T's which is a
video advertising company we're here
today to talk to you about easily moving
back and forth between batch and stream
processing pipelines depending on the
characteristics you know business needs
etc of that pipeline so as far as our
agenda goes today
I'm gonna do the first half and then
local take over after that in the first
half I'm gonna cover basically unified
model fundamentals within cloud dataflow
and Apache beam that make it possible to
easily switch between batch and
streaming mode depending on whatever
your use cases so it's gonna be four
main sections there one is I'm going to
define what do we mean by unified model
after that I'm going to go into the
infinite out of order datasets that
really kind of underlie the the whole
reason that we need this unified model
it's been a bunch of time talking about
the what where when and how model that
it really enables this this sort of
thing and then I'll finish up by
summarizing how all this conceptual
theoretical stuff enables batching
streaming and operability and then hand
after Loic and i will discuss about what
we do at EADS namely analyzing 30
billion events per day and for that I
will start by talking a bit about kids
the company who we are and what we do
then I will explain the architecture we
use for the past 3 years with the issues
and limitations we faced and the reason
why we moved to a new solution and I
will describe this new solution and give
you few lessons that we learned along
the way all right thank you so that I'll
go ahead and get started so before I
actually dive into the stuff I talked
about in the agenda I want to clarify up
front kind of the system's I'm gonna be
talking about so everything we're
talking about here was originally part
of Google Cloud dataflow the system that
we launched back in 2015 but about a
year ago we actually so there's two
things that are in the in cloud dataflow
there's this programming model and SDK
so these are the api's and sort of the
conceptual way of building data
processing pipelines
and then there's also this managed
service so this is the execution engine
that runs your pipelines for you once
you've written them right so about a
year ago we split these into two
separate projects essentially so there's
the programming of model and SDK were
donated to the Apache Software
Foundation as an fully community driven
open-source project and I'll be going
into some of the details about why that
happened today and then there's a couple
talks that I'll reference later tomorrow
that they're going to go into much more
detail about the community and sort of
the motivations behind it and things
like that and then the other portion
that that managed service portion that
lives within Google Cloud remain Google
Cloud dataflow so just so you have that
context as I kind of talk about things
you'll know what I'm talking about so
what do we mean by a unified model so
the the beginnings of the need for this
unified model really can kind of trace
back to early like 2011 so in 2011
timeframe stream processing was just
starting to become a thing and one of
the things that happened was stream
processing systems at the time like
Apache storm was that they they kind of
made design decisions in order to reduce
the latency that also reduced their
ability to provide correct results and
so Nathan Mars who wrote this blog post
who is also the creator of Apache storm
came up with this idea that you know
we'd like to have low latency results of
our system but we also want them to be
correct and our streaming systems can't
give us correctness
so instead why don't we do this this
this thing I'm going to call the land
architecture which is you know you've
got your data set on the on the left
there and you run it through some sort
of stream processing system that gives
you low latency but not really correct
results like Apache storm on the bottom
just calling it out because it's
Nathan's system and then you run out
also through a batch processing system
it gives you strong consistently strong
consistency like Apache Hadoop on top
you somehow merge the results together
at the end and and you could end up
getting what you want right you want
these low latency results that are
eventually correct the downside is that
you're you're building and maintaining
and then somehow merging the results
from two separate systems this is costly
among a ton of dimensions and so one of
the the big goals we set out to have
with with cloud dataflow
and then an Apache beam was to come up
with this unified model for doing this
so let you write your pipeline one time
and one way that lets you take your data
set and get your low latency but also
eventually correct results but what also
falls out from this is then once you've
once you've established this this sort
of a system you know it also allows you
to choose the trade-offs that you want
to make so if you're kind of okay in a
situation you know using a batch
processing engine on the backend and
trading off some of that latency for for
greater efficiency you can do that and
so so what you have is you've got your
but you're being pipeline you've written
and you've got to run it on something
right and so you can run it on a batch
system or you can run it on a streaming
system the choice is up to you
the big point is that you get to make
this informed decision that lets you you
know trade-off these tensions between
balancing you know correctness latency
and cost if you want to learn more about
the details of this we published a paper
on this vldb
in 2013 and so you can go look this up
and read through it and sort of see the
both the details of the underlying model
and really the the conceptual
motivations behind it but it's not just
about this you know trading off between
these these different tensions that
really motivated us to create beam
there's another aspect of it that's
really important as well and that is
this ability to run your pipeline really
on any supported runner and so it's not
just batch or streaming but really the
choice of whatever execution engine is
is the best for your specific use case
and then of course you're all here at
this this Google Cloud conference our
goal as Google cloud developer or Google
Cloud dataflow developers is to make
cloud dataflow the absolute best place
for you to go and run your being
pipelines but we being allows you to
have this this open source way of
accessing cloud dataflow that doesn't
lock you in to Google cloud you know
it's that open cloud sort of motivation
there and so you can come to Google
you've written your beam pipeline you
hand it off off to us and cloud dataflow
and we run it through our optimizer that
comes up with the best way to run it
possibly schedule isn't machines brings
up VMs integrates cleanly with all the
the various portions of the Google cloud
you know and all of this is done within
the managed service where you don't have
to do any of the
ops work to actually keep all this up
and running so that's sort of the the
rough introduction to you know what we
meant by the unified model and where it
came from so next let's look at infinite
out of order datasets because these were
really is really the motivating reason
for needing this unified model so in
order to do this I'm going to kind of
ground things in a conceptual or a
concrete example so imagine you are some
startup and you've created some new cool
mobile game where users go on their
phones and they crush candy or kill orcs
or whatever and as they do this you know
you're you're collecting logs about the
things they're doing like and through
our example that the biggest thing is
we're gonna say we're collecting user
scores right and we want to be able to
tally up user scores and team scores and
basically analyze the data and
understand how people are using our
product so we start out with the data
set so this is you know this is sort of
representing the logs from our games
writing each of these little squares is
one user score and as our our game gets
more popular our data set make it bigger
and eventually it make it so big that we
start organizing into some sort of
repeated structure right like we start
collecting logs for a given day you know
so tuesday's logs then wednesday's logs
but really this is just sort of a cheap
way of representing an infinite data
source and these the game game logs were
continuous to really want to treat them
in a continuous manner
what's worse because we're dealing with
distributed systems here and we're
dealing with mobile devices there's
ambiguity involved so let's look at a
few of these scores so we're gonna look
at three different scores from from
different gamers that all happened
conceptually at 8 a.m. so all of them
were on their phone at 8 a.m. and you
know made these scores so this first one
this red one here happened happened at 8
a.m. and you can see within our big
unbounded stream of data here it showed
up pretty close to 8 a.m. so that's
great and then this yellow one it was a
delayed a little bit but it also showed
up roughly close to 8 a.m. but then
somebody representing this Green Square
was you know on a plane or something in
airplane mode and they'd scored the
score date but it wasn't until you know
whatever that is five six hours later
that the
took the phone out of airplane mode and
we're able to upload that score so this
is what I mean when we talk about out of
order data sets like conceptually that
that score happened back a lot close to
where these two happened but we didn't
learn about it until hours later so now
we've got this infinite unbounded out of
out of order data set how do we process
it well there are a few different ways
that you can approach this depending on
what your pipeline is doing so the most
simple simple kind are element wives
transformations so with element wise
transformations you know you're just
doing things on an element by element
basis so in this case we're basically
filtering out everything except for the
yellow elements you don't have to look
at anything other than a single element
at any given time so it's relatively
straightforward another way to do this
you know once you start want to do an
aggregation you've got a group your
group your elements together somehow
over time so one way to do this is to
aggregate them into processing time
windows so you just basically break
apart time as elements arrive as sort of
they're observed in the stream and say
this is my window of time I'm gonna
treat this as you know a group of
elements together it's the simplest way
to do it but it also means if your
elements are arriving out of order they
may be processed within groups that they
don't really relate to so if you
remember that green element we had that
showed up you know way more like one
o'clock in the afternoon we would have
count that with all these other events
that happened around 1:00 instead of
with events that happened around 8:00
like we should have so what we really
want when you have when you're dealing
with with out of order data is event
time when doings so event time when
doing lets you take this unordered
stream of data and effectively perform a
time-based shuffle to put these put
these elements that arrive out of order
back into the order they should have
been and aggregate them together with
the elements that that you know they
belong with but to do this we really
need to formalize the relationship
between processing time and event time
so what we have here is a graph and
we're gonna actually look at a bunch of
graphs throughout this this presentation
but on the x-axis we have event time so
that's in blue so this is when the
events actually happened so the users on
their phone playing their game and they
you know they they scored some some
points and they were recorded that's the
event time
the processing time is then when the
events show up in the system we learn
about them and process them and I - line
up to the middle would be the ideal you
know if events happened and were
processed at the same time they'd all
lie on that ideal but reality is a
little more like this red curve where
you know because of distributed systems
because of delays in and from mobile
mobile phones etc you kind of get this
wandering meandering line that sometimes
comes close to the ideal but oftentimes
skis away from it and really this this
horizontal distance between the ideal
and this this red line this represents
the skew and event time so so how far
off are we from from the ideal as far as
you know completeness and event time and
in order to reason about completeness
and correctness we need to be able to
understand you know where that skew is
and so we do this with a thing called
the watermark and the watermark
essentially tries to capture the notion
of this red line it describes you know
progress of event time completeness
within the system it's it's roughly a
guarantee that no timestamp earlier than
the watermark will ever be seen again
now you can actually have two types of
watermarks depending on what your import
what input sources if you have complete
knowledge about your input source you're
actually able to provide a perfect
watermark which means this literally is
a guarantee you will never see a
timestamp earlier than the watermark
because we deal with distributed systems
or system you know systems like in our
case where we are reading from or we're
accepting you know mobile mobile phone
scores we've no way of knowing you know
all the mobile phones out there that
might be having scores made on them at a
given time and then uploaded later in
that case you often have to create
watermarks that our heuristic based so
you you you sort of take all the
information you know and make the best
estimate you can of what the watermark
is and then in that case you you may
actually be wrong and you'll have to
deal with that so there's two problems
then that they're listed here at the
bottom with watermarks one is that they
can be too slow if you know if you're
accurately holding back the watermark
because you know there's late data
that's fine but it also is kind of
you're essentially holding back progress
of the system waiting for this these
records that you know or late the others
that they can be too fast so the case of
having a heuristic watermark if your
heuristic is wrong if your your guesses
is off you'll say oh yeah the watermark
is advanced the timex but stuff stuff
with a timestamp before X may show up
later so that's that's a case of it
being too late so we'll look at ways
that we address that in the future but
that leads us to this next section so so
how do we deal with these these issues
well it's not not quite so hard if you
actually know what kinds of questions to
ask so what we've done with Apache beam
and cloud dataflow is try to provide a
system that lets you think about your
data processing problem by answering
these four simple questions so what is
it that you're competing you know are
you creating sums are you doing joins
are you building histograms machine
learning models this is sort of the the
question that you've traditionally
probably thought about answering with
classic batch processing but beyond that
when you want to start dealing with
these unbounded datasets there's a few
other questions you want to start
answering so we're an event time are you
actually performing these calculations
because when you have an unbalanced
infinite unbounded data set you can't
just assume that you'll wait till you
see the end of it because there may be
no end you're gonna have to chop it up
some way and then you know after you've
defined where an event time this is
happening when in processing time do you
actually emit results for it like do you
wait until you're you think your inputs
are complete do you want to give
speculative results over time that sort
of show your answer is evolving and in
cases where you have late data what do
you do if data show up late do you throw
them why'd you incorporate them in how
do you deal with this
and lastly then you know in cases where
you do provide multiple results
how do those refinements of those
results relate over time so we're gonna
go now through kind of an examples of
each of those questions and see what I
mean in more detail so for the what
question what are you computing we
talked previously about you know there's
element why is it operations there's
aggregations there's also this notion
within beam of composite operations so
taking a set of sort of more primitive
operations and turning them into a
higher level concept like a sum right
which is kind of a grouping and then a
addition operation reduction so for
example we're gonna we're gonna look
through some code here this is pseudo
Java because it needs to fit on slides
and we're gonna elide a lot of this as
we go the basic idea is you know we're
reading some log lines so that's that
first line we're reading them into a pea
collection the pea collection is the
beam and data flow notion of a massive
potentially massive collection of data
then we're going to apply these
transformations to it so first we're
going to apply a parser that's going to
parse it into this key value pairs of
strings and integers so these are going
to be team score pairs because we're
going to want to compute team scores
here and then lastly we're gonna apply
this composite some integers per key
operation which is just going to compute
these per team scores for us and so for
each of these examples we're going to
have again a you know an event time on
the x-axis green y-axis processing time
graph and each of these circles here
represents a single score from a single
user on the same team we're looking at
one one team at a time just because
otherwise it'd be three-dimensional on
it this is enough to deal with
and so this dashed line will sort of
represent that ideal if you remember
from the the watermarks slide I had
earlier and you can sort of see what you
know where these relate relative to that
idea like this this score of three is
really close relatively close to it so
what happened happened around what is it
fake it's all from a 12o almost 1207 and
it arrived not too shortly thereafter
but then you've got like this nine
example this this one actually showed up
quite a while after after it after the
event actually happened so you can see
there's that that much greater skew from
the ideal and so we're gonna look at a
few different animations so this is just
the sort of the initial pipeline we
talked about we're reading data and then
we computer some and so what's happening
here is there's this thick thick line
coming from the bottom the animation
just loops so you can kind of watch it
over and over this thick white line is
sending up the bottom represents time as
we observe it as the pipeline observes
these data coming in so as the line
reaches one of the elements it's
basically seeing that element and
incorporating it into the sum which you
can see accumulating there in the middle
and once it gets to the top it computes
its answer and the rectangle turns blue
and it materializes the result right oh
so this is pretty standard batch
processing so let's make it a little
more interesting and move forward and
start answering some more questions so
the first question I want to touch on is
we're an event time so the answer into
the where question is when doing so
windowing is a way of dividing data up
into event time finite base chunks so
this lets you get your your temporal
chunking within the data within this
infinite data stream so that you can
know where to where you know where
you're actually calculating within a
finite set of the data there's a few you
know a number of different examples of
types of windowing I have three up here
fixed windows where you know you
basically just slice up the data into
fixed you know say hourly Windows or
10-minute windows sliding is a lot like
fixed except you you slide a little bit
each time and so the interesting thing
there is that the windows start to
overlap and then sessions are a very
interesting example of windowing that we
won't go into detail here but basically
they're they're based off the data
themselves so you can't know ahead of
time what sessions are they actually try
to capture some quality of the data
itself so usually it's defined as you
see a sequence of activity for a given
key like for a given user they know
they're active on your website and you
you group them into groups of activity
that then terminate when the user stops
interacting with your service or
whatever so you can kind of see these
bursts of bursts of activity of the user
and they allow you to reason about
engagement levels and things like that
so they're very powerful and very
interesting but let's let's let's go
ahead and add some window into our
pipeline here so in order to do that in
beam you you just simply add this this
window and transform and it's it's it
reads quite plainly you know window tend
to fix windows of of two minutes long
and so if we then go back to our
animated example again running this on a
batch system you can see instead of
instead of accumulating a single result
we've we've now sliced it up into two
minutes slices of event time so in this
case we're looking at about nine minutes
of data so we end up with four different
scores across four two-minute windows
and again as before this is a batch
pipeline so we wait until we've seen all
the data and get our results at the end
but the whole point of this this talk is
to talk about being able to switch
between batch and streaming so let's see
what it takes then so then you know take
this and move it into streaming
so once we want to move into streaming
you know we can't wait until we've seen
all the input in order to produce
results so we've got to somehow figure
out a way of of producing results
earlier than that and that's when we
started to answer the wind question you
know when in processing time do we
materialize these results and we do that
with this thing called triggers so
triggers control when results are
emitted so what we'll do to begin with
is we'll add a trigger that says we're
going to trigger when the watermark
passes the end of the window this is
effectively the the default trigger so
we wouldn't need to specify this you
could actually use the code from the
previous example and a streaming
pipeline and get this effect and this is
also effectively the same thing that's
happening when you run a batch mode but
if we do this in within a streaming
example then we'll look first here at a
perfect watermark example so in this
case we have a watermark represented by
that - green line which is the perfect
watermark so it's it's going to
guarantee us that we never see late data
and basically what happens is the system
waits until the watermark passes the end
of the window and once it does it knows
okay I'm never gonna see any more data
for the for this window so it's okay to
go ahead and materialize the result for
it so you can see as before we get our
four results at 1422 three and twelve
but it does so in this sort of
incremental fashion as the the data for
those windows become complete and in
this way allows you to to continually
process an undoubted stream of data and
give your results that that kind of come
out as they go now let's look at another
example here next to it of a heuristic
watermark so let's imagine we have a
watermark that's not perfect and as you
can see it looks it looks different than
the then the dashed one this solid green
watermark is a little more aggressive
and it actually gets it wrong like it
doesn't know about that nine that ends
up showing up late and so what happens
here is that you know time progresses on
and we admit our windows as they come
but in that first window it sought it
was complete when it saw the five in the
watermark advanced and the later along
came the nine and there's nothing the
system could do about it like it just it
had already produced results so we got
the wrong answer we said five the answer
should have actually been 14 so how can
we deal with that so triggers provides
ways to deal with to deal with this so
in this case we can we can make our
trigger a little more a little more
complex to
deal with the subtleties of our specific
data sets so in this case we've added
two new two two modifications to the
watermark trigger we've said well we
want early firings every minute of
processing time so this is basically
going to give us speculative results as
our data evolve and then also to deal
with that things like that late nine
that showed up we're gonna say you know
if we ever get late data we're gonna go
ahead and and trigger a firing again any
time we see one we don't expect a whole
lot of late data so we'll just do it
anytime we see a key element count of
one and that way we will account for
these late records showing up so if we
then use this trigger we can see that
our two examples now look like this the
nice thing here is that in the heuristic
watermark case when that late night
shows up you can see we go ahead and
incorporate it and it gets incorporated
into a late result oh and each of the
panes here is annotated with you know
whether it's an early results or an
on-time results or a late result another
interesting feature of this you can see
is that it kind of helps with that that
that to slow problem of watermarks that
we talked about earlier so without the
early watermark you've kind of had to
wait you know almost 10 minutes to get
the get an answer of that first window
in the perfect watermark case even
though you knew it was at least 5 early
on whereas with this additional early
trigger that we put in here you start to
get these speculative results that let
you see your results build up over time
so that brings us to the last question
here so how do refinements relate when
we start having multiple panes within a
window how did the those panes relate to
each other so we're gonna look through
an example here where we're gonna have
three trigger firings a speculative
firing a watermark firing and a late
firing and for each of those you can see
which elements have showed up so we the
speculative firing will include a value
of three the watermark firing will
include a 5 and a 1 and then we'll get a
late firing with a value of 2 and we'll
look at each of the 3 different modes
that we have here to deal with defining
how refinements relate so the first one
is discarding mode or another way to
think of it as a sort of Delta mode so
when when the trigger fires we throw
away whatever state we built up whatever
something we've accumulated and kind of
start up start over again from 0 and so
you end up with these panes
three six and two that don't really
relate to each other in any way in the
last observed value has nothing to do
with the song even though we're going to
computing songs but if you sum them up
individually you do get the final sum so
this is this is useful for cases where
your outputs are actually going into
another system that's doing some further
aggregation the second one which is what
we've seen all along is accumulating
mode which actually holds on to that
that state that you've seen you can
think of this as maybe a value mode it
gives you the current value every time
so we see three first time then five and
one show up you add those together and
the next time the value is nine so every
time you can just kind of replace the
previous value with the new value to get
you know what is current and so that's
why you see the last observe there is 11
at the end it gives you that correct
result downside with this system is if
you actually sum those up themselves
you you kind of double count so you have
to make sure that this is used in a
system where you can overwrite previous
values where there's not going to be any
you know accumulation the one that you
really want which we don't have quite
implemented yet but is accumulating and
retracting mode which which which gives
you essentially accumulating mode but
also every time it gives you a new value
it gives you a retraction for the
previous value it says like with that
that on time firing it says well you
know previously I'd said the value was
three we'll take that away and retract
that and also here's the new value of
nine so that allows you to in situations
where you you know there may be further
aggregations down the pipeline you can
actually get this the correct result
that way or if you just look at the last
observed non retraction value you also
get the correct result so we'll look
real quickly at what adding a retracting
mode does to the pipeline so this is our
same example from before but now every
time we we fire a non initial pain you
see we get two pains we get both this
the the new result in yellow and then
also this retraction in red that's
saying you know the previous value that
I told you before will go ahead and get
rid of that because I was wrong and that
allows you to to really properly update
results over time even with without
having to just blindly overwrite a
previous value all right so before I
hand off to to Loic to hear about more
concrete
examples of this I want to talk very
quickly about how all this enables
Bastion streaming at all so it really
comes down to two things that are
provided by the system is this ability
for correctness in light of changing
inputs or different types of inputs and
in different ways of processing those
inputs under the covers and then the
flexibility afforded by the model to
make those choices so on the on the
correctness front you know we've talked
about distributed systems and how
they're you know they're distributed and
sort of you never know what you're gonna
get so to really quantify this for us
let's let's look at two examples of how
we might have observed these events so
you can see they're shifting up and down
between this this white set of input
records and this purple set you'll
notice that they aren't shifting in the
x-axis these these are the same events
they happen at the same time we're just
changing the order in which we observe
them within the pipeline we're changing
their processing time so if we were to
process these records using processing
time windows where you just sort of view
them as they come in what effectively is
happening is you're taking those events
you're throwing away the event time and
you're shifting them on to the ideal
you're saying you know when I saw this
event I'm gonna treat that as its
position in the window so your your your
your mapping processing time on to event
time and then summing things up and you
can see when you when you change the
ordering then you get different results
so the first window and ordering number
one you get a result of 12 in ordering 2
you get a result of 7 which isn't what
you want whereas if you use event time 1
doing where you actually you aggregate
and process these events within the
events the event time windows when they
happened you get the same result no
matter what the the processing time
ordering now the actual shape of results
over time as they sort of evolve may be
different like that's just a
characteristic of how your data arrive
but at the end of the day you come up
with the same results and this is a key
part of how you can provide a system
that operates the same even if it's in
streaming mode or in or in batch mode
the second part is flexibility so you
know the five examples we've walked
through you know you can see how the
system gives you the flexibility to
choose the ones that work for your use
case and specifically when we're talking
about switching between batch and
streaming there were three cases there
that they gave you the same final
results no matter whether it was batch
mode or in streaming mode and if you
don't care about late data really there
were four and so and we did this you
know with relatively minor code changes
I don't expect you to be able to read
this but the point is that you know we
didn't make a whole lot of different
changes to kind of fit these different
use cases and the really important point
is that we never we never changed our
core algorithm that sum of integers for
key and this is true no matter how
complex your algorithm is you you define
what it is you're computing and then
everything else you may need to change
in slight ways to tweak it for batch or
streaming it's totally independent of
that which really gives you the
flexibility to cleanly switch between
the two so I've now given you sort of
the theoretical conceptual foundation
for why we can support this switching
between batch of streaming I'm gonna now
hand off to look who's gonna give you a
little more concrete details of how
they've done that with their system at
teets thank you
Thank You Tara so yeah you're right the
proposal by total yeah today is going to
be to give you a feedback of our usage
of dataflow but also bigquery and more
broadly about GC B so as I mentioned in
the intro I will start by talking a bit
about kids so kids we created it in 2011
and we now have 27 offices in 21
countries in the world
last year we achieved the 200 million of
revenues we have 500 employees and among
them 90 plus of Emma from the oranga
team and what we do we try to solve a
major issue this advertising industry
has which is those car city of premium
video inventory only 5% of online video
in inventory is premium so we've created
a format to fix this issue so I have a
quick video to show you the formats in
action
all right okay so this is Dean Radin
[Music]
so you probably came across this format
so it's way too and that video will be
in editorial concerns so as you can see
the video is posed when it's not visible
and it's playing only when indivisible
and you can tap on the add to see it
full screen we stand so next slide with
the simple format in fact we've been
able to solve issue for the three main
actors of this industry
so first the publishers there's a lot of
pictures that they have a lot of text to
all content a they want to monetize this
content through video so with this
format from one day to the other one
they could monetize all the content with
video for advertisers they want who have
viewable ad which is what's the in read
does by design and they want to be
displayed within premium content which
we bring with the publishers that we
have and finally in the publishers the
users we try to create the format's in
such a way which is not intrusive which
is engaging for user and this way you
can skip the ad if you're not interested
or you can activate a sound if you are
interested and only if you are if you
are interested in the ad it's not
working
so today we are the number one video
marketplace in the world and we can see
on this graph the kind of growth that we
had during the past years I started in
2000 2012 until now and today we reach
more than 1.2 billion users every month
so we also within the club of you
websites reaching more than 1 billion
users so the question is what do we do
with this kind of data so nothing fancy
here we do bi for internal purpose we do
also analytics so we provide publishers
and advertisers with dashboard so they
can understand the website they can
understand how the ads are performing we
do also we optimize our algorithm
through machine learnings and I have
fused our use cases but the last one I
would like to mention is the fraud
detection so we started in 2012 and as
Tyler mentioned back then the code from
Nathan Marx was the reference and
basically the Nathan Nathan is
explaining in this code that data system
has two main features the first one is
the storage we need to ingest all the
data and the second one is the way we
retrieve and bring the result to the end
users but we have to keep in mind that
this kind of systems have a lifetime
which is pretty long so first our system
is running for 6 years and even more and
therefore we need to find a way to
overcome any kind of hardware failure
that could occur any kind of human
mistakes even though we try to avoid
them sometimes it happened so that's why
is really crucial to store raw data and
once you have raw data you can simply
apply a function to it and you can have
your end result so this is perfect but
the issue is that all data means a few
petabytes of data so it's not applicable
in real life so to solve this issue you
need to create some views pre computed
views to accelerate the queries so every
time you have a new use case a new
client asking for something you need to
create a new view to support this new
use case so we ended up operating and
managing lambda architecture so this is
the lambda architecture by by the book
and for us we are using we were using
Amazon Web Services so we are using
Kafka for the cue messaging then the
data as two ways the first one for the
batch layer so the first step is to
store the data so we can be safe data is
it there so for that we use what we call
the fetcher and we sold a town S 3 and
then the batch mode is computed it's
computing all these views on these
roll-ups and we used to do it in
MapReduce then we move to spark and we
store the end result in Cassandra on the
bottom of these charts you have the
build layer so for that we use storm and
once again the data is outputted in
Cassandra and for the final result we
are using a tool that we call reporting
that's merged in the data so if the data
is available in batch mode we are taking
this one otherwise we offer backing on
the real-time data that has been
computed through storm
so this kind of architecture is great
because you can fix any kind of issues
if you have stored data you can recreate
it from scratch so you can just discard
the batch data and then use the raw data
to compute the new views and you find
again you fix the issues and share it on
the cake you can even create views for
needs you didn't think of previously
because you have the data to support
this few numbers so I should have
mentioned that we are using Hadoop for
both the spark jobs and then to use the
reporting so there's two usage for the
Hadoop cluster we have a Hadoop cluster
of around 120 nodes our class and
Cassandra cluster is around 60 nodes and
we ingest everyday around 4 terabytes of
data and this is done only with the team
of three people so with this kind of
scale you start to face limitations so
just name a few the numbers of you you
need to create to support all your
client needs than to grow very fast so
you have to create a lot of them and
therefore when there's a mistake and you
need to recompute all those views it's
quite expensive you also need to create
some internal jobs to add some steps to
bring the end result and therefore you
are you ended up with a lot of
complexity and finally not least because
you are managing those big clusters it's
involve a lot of work in terms of
monitoring automation and so on so it
doesn't scale magically so we started to
think about an ideal solution for us
which would be use
only one single unified view and
therefore with this view we could have
all the combinations possible and
combine all the dimensions with it we
wanted it to be really fast to be able
to compute those views in Knotts days
and finally if possible it would be
manageable more manageable that's the
previous system and why not managed by
someone else if you see what I mean
so that's why we tried to run a POC with
bigquery so as our data were laying on
s3 we just transferred the data to DCP
using that data transfer and then
because at the time pocket was not
supported we added a step with that
approach to convert data and ingest the
data in bigquery so since then packets
pot has been developed so it would be
easier if I had to do is each now once
you have the data you can try to play
with it and to create this unified view
we were eager 12 so this is how the data
looks like when we try to ingest it
there's basically a timestamp and a few
ideas
so advertised advertisement ID website
ID there's tons of them and finally does
the event so the first thing we can do
is try to compress the data because we
do not provide reports per minute but
per hour so we could get rid of the
timestamp and replace it by the hour
plus a counter so this is the first step
which is fine but we can go even deeper
something we want to do is to use
dedicated column for every kind of
events
that we can have so other currents for
impression I can start and finally
another one for clicks and this way we
can go from four rows in the first
example to only one with three counters
two impressions one start and one click
and you can leverage the columnar
storage system of bickering because if
you want very only impressions you can
just read those integer instead of
having to scroll and read string which
is way faster and as the data is quite
similar it's a good use case for
compression so this way we've been
achieved to compress the data by 70 X
and we try to run privy to it so we've
been impressed by the performance of
Vickery and we in fact achieved better
results and better performance on this
hourly roll-up than the previous system
invent though it was optimized for free
so with this success we moved on to the
next step which involved dataflow which
is the live ingestion of the data so as
we have this queue messaging Kafka we
just plugged data flow to it
so keep in mind that we are using two
different cloud providers so data flow
is responsible to retrieve the data to
aid us from a degrees and to inserts
it's in the query so it was really
really easy to do because we perform
very few
modifications on the data and was
working fine but there's a few
challenges that would like to discuss
the first one is I think pretty obvious
I think to clouds add bits of complexity
so we need to handle this we need to
avoid creating the same stuff 20 times
so for instance you have the your rights
on one cloud provider and the same one
on the second one that need to be kept
in sync same goes for network
configuration and so on so we are
investing a lot in terraform and I think
you should do the same even though you
only operate on one cloud provider it's
a good use use that of your time and
second issue that we faced it's not
really linked that the flow but small to
bickering so data flow is refastened
pretty cheap but when you are trying to
ingest raw data which means more
terabytes per day the streaming mode of
bigquery could be a bit expensive and we
start to think about those questions
that we mentioned do we need to go to
stream or batch and we we acknowledge
that it was not right to use case for
the streaming mode so we switched to
what we call the micro batch meaning
batch every 15 minutes which is fine for
our use case and we also think about all
the solutions like sampling the data
when it's technical metrics when you
just need a trend and not exact value
and this kind of stuff so this is the
end result you have your timeline with
the events the color is representing the
hour of data generation so first it's
mostly outward fine but you can't have
late events and we just read the batch
of data a chunk of data using data flow
right it's to betray so without a lot of
modifications just a few checks and
casting and then we are leveraging the
SQL poor and we create those roll-ups
mentioned before and we are separating
the data from the hour of 7:00 a.m. from
8 a.m. and we write those in two
different tables and then as time goes
by there's new events that need to be
processed so first step ingestion on
bigquery using data flow and then we
opened the data and you can see I guess
understood the principle okay so this is
the overview and the final final
architecture so Kefka data flow
consuming the data writing it to
bigquery then applying SQL query to
generate those roll-ups and we can go
even deeper with new queries to create
specialized data Mart's for specific
needs in case of we need those so I just
want to go back I mention this before
the fraud detection so right now we have
a loop which is every hour we are
retrieving the data we are checking to
see if there's any fraud or anomaly
detection and we think this is a perfect
use case to leverage the streaming mode
of data flow and try to speed up a bit
this feedback loop to have a faster
feedback results so in terms of results
we've been able to shrink how our
cluster so the other cluster equivalent
of Hadoop goes from hundred and twenty
dollars
thirty two nodes we no longer need
Cassandra and we are using a bakery
which is managed so no nodes are to
manage you can see there's more that
data on bakery because we do no longer
need to discard the raw data and we can
keep it on bakery and use it when we
need it
volumes st. in size is the same and this
the pork the pirate has been done in
only four months so few more slides in
terms of scale we were reaching the
limits we were wondering if it was
possible to to scale to the next level
because he took us around 40 minutes to
compute one hour of data so we were
wondering if it was possible to scale
and now we know for sure that's the case
because we tried with ten times more
data and it's working fine and in fact
the times to process one hour of data
have been down to only four minutes so
for batch of one minutes four minutes
which is impressive in terms of cost you
would cry out used to require a lot of
maintenance to end all those big
clusters and it was pretty expensive so
now we've dedicated basically all this
job to bickering and to Google so it's
managed for us so the cost of
operational I've been down to close to
zero and we all know now under control
and regarding the cost something I would
like to mention is that the cost has
been reduced even though we have around
for around 20 percent of the overall
cost which is the egress to transfer the
data from one cloud to the other one so
there's room of optimization
in terms of complexity instead of having
to chain all those long jobs and yeah
and manage a role and retries we just
have only two steps ingest data and do
the roll-ups and the data is now
actionable because it no longer requires
you to write spark jobs or complicated
stuff like that you can just leverage
the SQL query so basically anyone with
basic SQL knowledge could leverage the
data and use it and finally we are now
we are having a single role up instead
of partial roll-ups so we can combine
everything and we can combine all the
dimensions and answer questions we were
not able to answer previously and I
would like to conclude this talk by
congratulating the wonderful team that
work on this so this is not extreme and
thank you for them
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]